[Music]
it's a hard path
the life of a hero people depend on you
even if you were in a battle sometimes
they die I don't know if I could be the
next Iron Man
got gifts Parker
the world needs that
a friends are in trouble drawl
the question is what are you gonna do
about it
superhero stuff
I gotta get you guys out of here no the
jet who are you I work with spider-man
who answered spider-man I work with
spider-man not for spider-man come on
vacation man who's this some refugees
get around
[Music]
No
[Music]
okay
[Music]
this is mr. Beck but you handled
yourself well out there today so what
you did with the tower Thanks
they were born in stable orbits within
black holes creatures forms from the
primary elements air water fire earth
the science division had a technical
name we just called them elementals
versions of them exists across our
mythologies turns out the myths are real
like Bora Bora was amazing now I study
him in my physics class these myths of
threats they first materialized on my
earth many years ago I was part of the
last battalion life trying to stop them
all we did was delay the inevitable the
elementals are here now attacking the
same coordinates our satellites confirm
it we have one mission kill it
you're coming with us it's a fury this
all seems like big time you know huge
superhero kind of stuff and I mean I'm
just a friendly neighborhood spider-man
sir please you've been to space okay we
beat the rush you here to rush out lucky
for us we got the best seats in the
house let's go
you look really pretty and therefore I
have value no no that's not what I meant
at all I was just I'm messing with you
thank you you're welcome
you look pretty too so cute want to go
in on a pair you mean that's it next to
each other yeah no okay no I didn't mean
that uh if you go ahead I'll go grab us
a pair don't become anything
fury asked me to come up here and see
how you were doing he just he felt bad
about snapping at ya really you guys do
have sarcasm on this earth right how you
feeling I didn't think I was gonna have
to save the world this summer I know
that makes me sound like such a jerk I
just I had this plan with this girl that
I really like him now it's all ruined I
like you Peter a good kid
there's a part of me that wants me to
tell you just turn around run away from
all this and then there's another part
of me that knows what we're about to
fight what's at stake I'm glad you're
here
me too but you're worried about your
friends yeah
just always feel like I'm putting them
to danger look just get him inside and
keep them in a safe place for just a few
hours they'll be all right it's really
nice to have somebody to talk to you
about superhero stuff you know anytime I
need a suit suit you take care of the
suit I'll take care of the music
[Music]
we start off in the iron spider suit
that was amazing that was obviously we
have the homecoming suit which is very
dear to my heart I love that suit
I forgot that I can't [ __ ] my face and
then there's the stealth suit which is
my favorite suit because it's totally
different and totally fresh the idea
behind the suit is Peter Parker doesn't
want to be seen as spider-man in Europe
so Nick Fury loans him this costume
coming out the shield special locks
world how's the suit mister it's great
it's awesome it's kind of Captain
America like with a spider-man twist do
you think it's pirate no no no it's like
a European ripoff version of them I was
actually reading the other day it's not
and it also looks pretty bad
[Music]
so the black and red suit despite
wearing a work of art it looks so
realistic that feels like you should be
able to climb walls and you should be
able to shoot webs and the way that it's
made is an homage to the godfather of
the MCU the world needs the next Iron
Man
[Music]
I'm so good hey so I am late happy you
look nice
thank you you too thank you new dress
yes it is hot you know what just
happened
[Music]
which past Britain Peter Parker here to
pick up a passport please
many to space let's go pack your suit I
just want to go on my trip with my
friends Europe doesn't really need a
friendly neighborhood spy
we look really pretty therefore I have
value no that's not a nice thing see you
look pretty too I just spent some time
with NZ watch YouTube I'll do my first
unloved I have just finished my school
coffee
so nice to finally meet you spider-man
your Nick Fury put some clothes on let's
go for a ride is she gonna be okay like
that might want to turn him over so he
doesn't swallow his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
got gifts Parker a job to do are you
going to step up or not
we're all alone
your friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one
he's no spider-man what is it with you
and spider-man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect him
sup dickwad Tom is it is yen nice to
meet you
thank you just Tom Hiddleston yeah what
okay sure
tell me about spider-man why was it Thor
in that one oh because you know he's
really feel like the front-running
Avengers in this movie you know it's all
about kind of who's gonna step up and
take our DJ spot which is why I asked
where was I was thought that's what the
last time I saw you you were you were a
little bit portly yeah yeah how have you
I mean oh it was a full method on that
one why my Oscar attempt yeah and so I
sort of blew out intentionally a beard
the baby's real pretty I'm pretty sure
everyone in the bag actual ready cleared
the mantelpiece full thing I imagine so
I saw a copy of this down at the markets
in CUDA did you say recast you already
who with Jake Gyllenhaal oh really
Tom who's your favorite actor in the
whole world you can see him Hemsworth
he's up there man he's great he's going
games really good any other Hemsworth's
Luke Hemsworth so super talented yeah
super super fun warheads with any would
there be I think would start with the
sea India Hemsworth has potential she
grow up to be a very actress one way I'm
sure okay let's move on child spent
minute black I just knew this one was
gonna be like slam dunk amazing thank
you thank you
everyone's Hussein on a set of state
favorite film in history of cinema
they have who's seen it the smartest
group of people right in the world we
assembled them and he found like
Avengers but yeah critically Sam I went
and washed it and said best movie
all-time high base film it's only super
exciting and it's adventurous and the
actions way bigger and it's just like
the continuation of the biggest
cinematic moment in history
terrific amazing thank you
everywhere I go I see his face
missin ya missin too I don't think Tony
would have done what he did if he didn't
know that you were gonna be here after
he was gone
you're gonna be a next Ironman now well
no I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation
[Music]
heads up Nick Fury's calling me I don't
really want to talk to me that's all why
because if you don't talk to him and I
have to talk I don't want to talk about
you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I gotta
go you do not ghost Nick Fury
darts what's up we're just talking about
the trip oh I think MJ really likes me
when I first Aloha you're a very
difficult person to contact spider-man
this is mr. Veeck we're gonna use
someone like you on my world new world
Vick is from Earth just not ours
a snap to our home in our dimension we
have a job to do
you're coming with us
[Music]
offworld catch him home unavailable
but who's the friendly neighborhood
spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want Peter I want to go back on
my trip with the girl you I really like
you tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course I mean
it's kind of obvious you're right you
may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
it's always feel like I'm putting my
friends in danger
the world needs next Ironman you're
going to step up or not
[Music]
here I work with spider-man you were
through spire I won't win spider-man not
for spider-man
[Music]